my ultimate 50 lunch would always be a
soup soups are really versatile and
great fusing up ingredients you've
already got but best of all I absolutely
love them and this is one of my
favorites a comforting smoky bacon sweet
corn and potato soup
thrifty for me is about ingredients that
are in the cupboard smoky bacon onions
potatoes sweet corn
it's amazing how cheap the ingredients
are that go into this get your bacon and
just cut into nice chunks some of these
nice bite-sized pieces
smoky chunky and just absolutely
delicious it's almost like an American
corn chowder takers give this starch
thickness sweet corn gives you that
glassy delicious flavor a couple of
babies they're always hanging around if
they're not in your cupboard they're on
someone's drive so ask to borrow them
they are so powerful and it goes
brilliantly well with the onions and the
bacon Bailey's in a couple of potatoes
it's incredible how far you can stretch
something out especially when you bulk
it with potatoes slice em and dice them
nice and chunky soups are a fantastic
way to use up leftover veg or made that
might otherwise go to waste and if you
make it in bulk freeze it in individual
portions and save on lunches throughout
the week so you see already how hearty
and robust the soup is it's a delicious
combination onions bacon potatoes and
now some fresh leeks
open up the leek into four give that a
nice wash legs often have soil left in
their tops so it's important to clean
them thoroughly start sweating that down
we don't even got the corn in there yet
and already it's looking and smelling
incredible add salt but remember you've
got bacon in there which is salty so
proceed with caution really important to
sweat those potatoes off I loved getting
that flavor from the smoky bacon in with
the potatoes
now once the leek is spin it off creamed
corn
a popular side dish in the States
creamed corn is made from fresh frozen
or even tin corn cooked with onion
butter and cream and can be bought
ready-made that starts to give the
foundation the soup after creamed corn
and the sweet corn then your stop don't
flood the soup just bring the stock to
underneath ingredients you can always
add very difficult to take away homemade
chicken stock is so cheap to make
just boil up your roast chicken bones
with a few fresh veg and freeze in
batches for when you need it
lighten the load with a touch of milk
that gives a really nice bright color
now bring out to the ball turn it down
and let it simmer for 12 to 15 minutes
as it cooks slowly the starch thickens
the soup the bacon renders and that leek
onion starts the puree and the corn just
shines okay next we're gonna make the
American cheese biscuits in the UK
they're known as scones but in America
they called biscuits
[Music]
first put plain flour into a sieve and
baking powder and sift both into a bowl
next add some salt pepper and grated
mature cheddar cheese mix the dry
ingredients and make it well in the
center pour in double cream and gently
combined with a wooden spoon
[Applause]
[Music]
turn your dough out onto a floured
surface and knead for a few seconds only
if you overwork it
your cheese biscuits won't rise roll out
your dough to about two centimeter thick
and cut into four centimeter round
biscuits
place well apart on a lined baking sheet
and leave to rest on the tray for about
10 minutes then brush the top of each
biscuits with melted butter and bake for
about 30 minutes at a hundred and sixty
degrees C in a preheated oven when you
cheese biscuits are well risen and a
beautiful golden brown remove the
deliciously moreish served hot or cold
time to dole out my thrifty lunch I
always like to leave a soup to stand or
rest it looks richer gets rid of all the
stock I like to have two-thirds
ingredient one third of the stock so it
looks like a nice delicious chunky soup
into the bowl
[Music]
beautiful tin sweet corn a leek potato
is some streaky bacon but it doesn't
look like it's just coming out of a
store cupboard that is proper hearty
food
[Music]
served with my american-style cheese
biscuits this 50 lunch may have been
made on a shoestring but without an
ounce of compromise on freshness and
flavor
[Music]